Je reviens du marché.
Regardez, j'ai acheté des piments.
Il faut dire que, je n'avais
que l'embarras du choix.
Il en existe plus de 1000 variétés.
Certains ont des notes sucrées
presque caramélisées
d'autres sont plus fruités
ou plus fumés.
sont plus fruitées ou plus fumées.
Certains ont même des nuances
d'herbes aromatiques.
Bref, le piment, il y en a pour toutes
les sauces et tous les goûts.
En revanche, ils ont un point commun.
Cherchez bien, allez, vous brûlez !
Ah bah, c'est ça justement,
il brûle.
Allez, dans l'atelier, on va faire
le point sur ce sujet brûlant !
Allumer le feu !!!
Le piment est originaire d'Amérique latine.
Il était déjà utilisé dans de nombreux plats lorsque Christophe Colomb l'a découvert au cours de son premier voyage à Cuba, en 1492.
A l'époque, il aromatisait même le chocolat des Mayas et des Aztèques.
Vous imaginez ?
Vous imaginez aromatiser le chocolat...
Tu piques alors ?
Les conquistadors espagnols l'ont ensuite ramené en Europe,
où il a tout de suite remporté un succès fou.
Dès 1526, on le cultive dans toute l'Espagne, d'où
il se répand sur toute la planète.
Bien sûr, chacun l'a un peu arrangé à sa sauce.
En France, les choses se sont passées plus lentement.
Le piment est arrivé d'Espagne via le Pays basque
et le Languedoc au XVIIe siècle
en passant notamment par le village d'Espelette,
d'où le piment d'Espelette justement.
Mais ce n'est qu'au XXe siècle, lorsque les cuisines exotiques chinoises, vietnamiennes ou indiennes sont devenues à la mode
que le piment a vraiment explosé.
Et dans certaines recettes, il faut bien le dire, c'est une véritable
explosion de saveurs pour nos papilles.
Suivez-moi en cuisine, je vous explique pourquoi.
Cette sensation de brûlure est provoquée par la capsaïcine
un composé chimique de la même famille que la nicotine et la caféine
que l'on retrouve dans la chair du piment.
Quand on croque dans un piment, la capsaïcine se lie avec des récepteurs qui se trouvent sur la langue
et qu'on appelle des nocicepteurs.
Le problème, c'est que ces récepteurs sont
les mêmes que ceux qui réagissent à la chaleur.
Du coup, le cerveau reçoit le même signal que lorsque
que l'on a quelque chose de chaud sur la langue.
Chaud devant ! Chaud !
D'où cette sensation de chaleur, voir de brûlure
quand on croque un piment.
Mais je vous rassure,
il ne s'agit bien que d'une sensation.
Aucun risque de se brûler la langue
réellement avec un piment.
La preuve !
Ça brûle !
Et pourtant. 37,5°C.
La température reste bien la même.
Ça brule vraiment.
En fait, la présence de cette molécule
de capsaïcine dans le piment
est un mécanisme de défense, une façon
de dissuader les prédateurs trop gourmands.
Eh oui, les animaux n'aiment pas manger trop épicé.
Nous non plus, d'ailleurs.
En 2018, en voulant relever un défi,
un Américain de 34 ans a fini à l'hôpital
après avoir mangé un Carolina Reaper,
un piment parmi les plus forts du monde.
Bon, beh je vais plutôt me faire des pâtes.
C'est dur, mais c'est doux.
Pas la peine de t'enflammer, certains piments sont très doux,
le poivron ou le paprika, par exemple.
Pour le savoir, il suffit de consulter
ce que l'on appelle l'échelle de Scoville.
Elle mesure en unités Scoville la concentration
en capsaïcine et donc la force du piment.
Un peu comme l'échelle de Richter a été utilisée
pour mesurer l'intensité des tremblements de terre.
Son créateur, l'Américain Wilbur Scoville, a eu l'idée
de faire goûter une purée de piments frais
à cinq personnes et de compter le nombre
de dilution dans de l'eau sucrée
pour que ces cinq cobayes n'aient
plus aucune sensation de brûlure.
Le poivron, qui fait partie de la famille des piments,
mais qui ne contient pas du tout de capsaïcine
est tout en bas de l'échelle à zéro.
Le piment d'Espelette ne chiffre
qu'entre 1500 et 2500 unités Scoville.
Le piment de Cayenne, un peu plus costaud,
doit être dilué entre 30 et 50 000 fois.
Alors que le piment Pepper X, désigné
comme le plus fort du monde en 2017,
est à 3 millions de dilution,
soit 180 000 unités Scoville.
Renversant !
Je suis sûr qu'une question
vous brûle encore les lèvres.
Que faire pour soulager
cette sensation de bouche en feu ?
De l'eau ! De l'eau !
Je vais plutôt commander un verre de lait.
Un verre de lait patron, enfin patronne.
Merci !
Un verre d'eau, même glacé, n'aide pas, au contraire.
L'eau ne fait que disperser la capsaïcine dans la bouche.
La capsaïcine n'est pas hydrosoluble, elle est liposoluble.
Elle ne se dissout pas dans l'eau, mais dans un corps gras
lorsque l'on mange un plat un peu trop pimenté.
Il vaut donc mieux boire un verre de lait entier
pour calmer le feu dans la bouche
ou bien manger un yaourt entier
qui contient du gras
ou alors avaler une cuillerée d'huile d'olive.
Allez, racontez moi vos expériences
en commentaire de cette vidéo
ça mettra un peu de piment dans ma vie !
À très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo.